you've written on your website that
quote i prefer listening to talking
reading to socializing and cozy chats to
group settings
so i think this conversation on the
podcast is gonna be fun uh what's a good
definition of an introvert is something
like
those three things a good start
it is a good start in terms of how
introverts experience day to day life um
i think a good definition is one that
some of your listeners will have heard
many times before you know the idea of
where do you get your energy and for
some people they get their energy more
from
quieter settings and for other people
they get it more from being out there
so a good rule of thumb is to ask to
imagine that you're at a party that
you're really enjoying and you've been
there for about two hours or so and it's
with people you really like
and it's in your favorite place so it's
all good
an extrovert in a setting like that is
going to feel
charged up and they're going to be
looking for the after party
and an introvert no matter how good a
time they're having and how socially
skilled they are there's this moment
where you just like wish that you could
teleport and be back at home
yeah
and at the time before the start of the
party to the the time of that moment
happens is different for different
people so like the shorter that is the
more of an is where you are is that that
kind of thing the shorter the moment
until you get to the place where you've
got to teleport home
yeah and then for extroverts it's the
opposite right like they're gonna feel
you know maybe they're working on uh i
don't know like focused on producing a
memo that's really intensely interesting
to them but if they're in that state of
like solitary
the solitary mode of really focusing
they might get stir-crazy a lot faster
than an introvert would
and so it doesn't have so much to do
with what you're good at as
how you get your energy and so
for an introvert the source of energy is
what silence
solitude and for an extrovert it's
interaction with other people
what i'd really say is that and this is
neurobiological as well is that it has
to do with um how your nervous system
reacts to stimulation
so for an introvert
you're feeling in a great state of
equilibrium when there are fewer inputs
coming at you so they could be social
inputs but that's why an introvert in
general would rather like hang out with
one close friend at a time as opposed to
you know big party full of strangers
because that's too many inputs for the
nervous system and for an extrovert
the nervous system needs more stimulants
so if they're not getting enough they
get that listless and sluggish feeling
so if you're just walking through the
world
like people listening to this but in
general
how do you know if you're an introvert
like how do you empirically start to
determine
if you are in large part an introvert
well
i would start by just asking that
question of what happens to you um you
know at around the two hour mark where
you're having a good time yeah like i
mean imagine today but but i also find
i'm curious if you have a different
experience from this but from all the
years that i've been out there talking
about this topic i found that
most people really seem to know once
they're being honest with themselves and
maybe that's the question to ask is like
if you imagine that you have
a saturday or a whole weekend where you
can spend your time exactly the way you
want to with no professional obligations
and no social obligations who would you
spend it with how many people what would
you be doing
and and what is that picture that you're
painting start to look like
yeah
so there's nuance to this though because
i'm sure for extroverts to get energized
by
stimulation whether that's stimulation
with other people like it depends what
that stimulation is right
like maybe you're not surrounded by the
kind of people that you enjoy being
around
so you know um
maybe that has to do less with whether
some characteristics is your personality
more has to do with the fact what like
what your environment is like that's
always kind of
uh the question do you want to be alone
because everybody around you is an
[ __ ] or do you want to be alone
because you get energized from being
well i would hold the variables constant
i guess i would say
you know
keep the [ __ ] constant and see
and then there's the other thing you
kind of observe that there's a lot of
people
that will say they get energized from
being alone
like
people are exhausting to them or
something like that but at the same time
when you see them at a party they seem
like the life of the party i know and i
hear from those people all the time
there are so many people like what would
you classify them as exactly is it
ultimately as the source of energy is
the most important thing or like how the
heck are they the life of the party it's
a bunch of different things you know so
first of all just to say like a big
caveat to all of this is humans are just
amazingly complex so you can't
like explain every individual humans
through these parameters even though i
think the parameters are really valuable
but that person at the party it could be
that they're more of an ambivert so they
kind of are more in the middle of the
spectrum that's it basically means
someone who's not extremely introverted
or extremely extroverted they're kind of
in the middle so maybe at a party their
more extroverted side comes out
or it could be
an introvert who's gotten
really good at the skills of acting more
like a pseudo-extrovert and they pull
that up at the moment that they need it
so they've learned how to fake it yeah
oh there's a lot of people like that and
i know this because
like i think out of all the people on
this planet you could be talking to i've
heard from the most number of those
people like they all come and tell me
about their experience
out in the world presenting a face
that's different from what they feel so
one of the things you talk about is
at least in the west we've constructed a
picture of success
and that picture
is usually one of an extrovert like when
you imagine somebody who's a leader
who's a successful person
that person has some of the qualities
you would associate with an extrovert
and so
there's a lot of incentive
for uh faking it
yeah exactly if you if you want to be
successful you got to be able to to fake
it to sort of uh
hang with the rest of the team you have
to you have to be able to be outgoing
and all those kinds of things and not be
drained by the interaction yeah but i
mean there are also a lot of introverts
who figure out ways to draw on their own
strengths and they're incredibly
connecting and successful and they're
great leaders and they're not actually
faking it they're more just figuring out
ways to do it their own way
you see a lot of people like that
is there advice is there lessons you can
draw from that from just observing how
you can be an introvert and be in a
leadership position
yeah it's kind of like a mantra of
figuring out what your own strengths are
and how to draw on them um i think of
a guy i know doug conant who
had been the ceo of campbell's soup for
many years he's very introverted he's
quite shy also by his own description
and
and he really cares about people
and so when he started
at campbell um the employee engagement
ratings of the company were all the way
at the bottom of the fortune 500 and by
the time he stepped down 10 years later
they were all the way at the top
and
he was it wasn't that he was going out
there and schmoozing people
but he really did care so he would find
out who are the people who had really
been contributing
and he would write to them personal
letters of thanks
and um
and people and these letters meant so
much to people they would like carry
them around with them and during his
time the 10 years there he wrote 30 000
of those letters
so like that was his way of doing it
that was his way of drawing on his own
strengths and and you know like he did
that together with of course you
sometimes have to go outside your
comfort zone no matter who you are so he
was doing plenty of that too yeah it's
kind of combination
yeah that
the writing process and focusing on the
one-on-one interaction
i can definitely relate there's
something deeply draining which concerns
me about like zoom meetings
because it's some weird brain
manipulation wait say more well
because you're not really engaged
but it wears on you the same way that it
does a party it feels like you're
emptying that bucket for the introverts
even though they're not participating at
all in the meeting i mean i suppose
that's true for physical meetings too
but with zoom meetings remote meetings
it's so much easier to invite a larger
number of people into the meeting
so you're draining more and more of the
introvert energy and i'm probably
extrovert too but the introvert
definitely there's i mean it's
interesting i i would love to understand
that more because there's more and more
push towards remote work
without i think a deep understanding of
why these meetings are so draining on
people i just anecdotally i've heard
from that but maybe that's because the
managers the people who arrange the
meetings are just not
sufficiently yet aware of the draining
nature of them so that they pull in too
many people they schedule them too
regularly so they need to adjust that
kind of thing probably i think people
are starting to realize but
i i would say one reason that zoom is so
draining is because
you can see your own self presentation
the whole time if you choose to
and
when you go into in person you can't so
you're kind of afraid of thinking about
that so it's like an extra cognitive
load that you're bearing the whole time
oh yeah and like you might want to you
know turn off the camera so you can't
see yourself but then you feel like well
i have the ability to so i probably
should be doing it and then that alone
is a decision that you're making yeah
there's probably studies on this now
happening either have happened or are
happening
of the effect of seeing your own
face on on camera because it's reminding
you that you're supposed to be acting a
certain way and that's
that is especially a stressful thing
yeah you can't be in the moment as much
but i mean for you you you make the
decision to do all your podcast
interviews in person right yeah and so
and that's
even when it's very costly if there's
any kind of chemistry that contributes
at all
to the conversation which i think most
conversations have chemistry even the
boring work meanings there's something
there
because yes you're trying to solve a
particular problem at this particular
time
but underneath it there's a team
building that's happening and
honestly people also
have told me about this why they enjoyed
the zoom meetings during
uh the pandemic
it's like they're lonely yeah yeah like
they
you know it's annoying to have to sit
and listen to folks talk about nothing
and so on but they they tune in anyway
because
it's kind of lonely to sit there by
yourself and that
i mean there's a deep connection there
when you're with other people and that
is especially true when they're you
they're in person which is a huge
concern for me for like more and more
offices
from a capitalist perspective
realizing hey why are we why do we have
these large office spaces why do we have
to get people together but i think in
some in some deep sounds we do but then
you also talk about that once we do we
want to protect
the introverts
like you don't want the open
space which office space which was a big
fad for a while i don't know where
people stand on that at this point yeah
i think people are figuring it out in a
post-pandemic context but
i mean i know what you mean
so
before i became a writer i was a
corporate lawyer for like seven years
and
literally the only thing i miss from
those years
is hanging out with
people
at the office like
i don't know just some of the funniest
moments i've had in my life came from
being at the office until midnight with
the other people i was working with so i
know exactly what you're talking about
so i will say the offices there at that
firm and at most firms in those days
everybody had their own office so it was
like a dorm room you know where it was
like a long hallway with everybody in
their own little dorm room
um so you had tons of privacy but you
would also come out and
hang out with people you could
roam whenever you want
yeah yeah and whenever you roam that
means you're kind of open
you're looking for trouble
for interaction and the extent to which
you would keep your door open you know
was it wide open or was it half a jar or
just a little bit those are all signals
so is there because you said re-energize
is there do you like to think and again
the human mind is complicated but do you
like to think of it as like a bucket
that gets refilled
for introverts in terms of energy of
um
social interaction that that that
they're
able to uh handle is do you think of it
like that
as a bucket that gets emptied and needs
to be refilled i think of it yeah more
or less because i use the metaphor of a
battery that gets recharged or not it's
basically the same thing different
metaphor um but yeah but just to add on
that that there is a layer of complexity
to that because
you could be somebody who
doesn't want the kind of social life
let's say where you have to be like on
and presenting and interacting with tons
of people all the time but you'd get
really lonely if you were just by
yourself you know so what you want is to
maybe be in the company of a couple
people you know really well
like for me the pandemic was not
actually that hard for me personally i
mean i i lost family but i mean from the
point of view of what we're talking
about it wasn't that hard because i live
with my husband and my kids
so i knew it was hard on the kids and i
felt badly for them but for me i was
like
you know what
i kind of i have a lot of social life
right here in the house
and i can focus and do my work
yeah
that's the cool thing about that
pandemic i think it helped people figure
out how much they love their family i
think that's true um and and allow you
give you a chance to really reconnect
with kids
uh with your kids like really spend time
with them it's just fascinating to watch
like people actually it did strengthen
the family unit in a often beautiful
way
which just sucks to me too to have to
leave behind at this point yeah and i
think that's part of what people are not
going to want to go back to that we need
to solve for um
to the extent that work becomes
non-remote again yeah i think people
have just realized how precious those
aspects of their lives are and you know
for somebody who's in a sort of
conventional office job where you're
going home and seeing your kids for an
hour before bedtime and that's your
interaction with them
that's
that's kind of a ridiculous way to set
things up yeah it's cool that you can
get i think a lot of places give you the
option now which is interesting you get
to optimize that element of your life
you take the commute and the office work
and then the social interaction there do
you focus on the work at home
it's also lonely at home but then you
get to see your kids if you have kids
that's part of the optimization is like
i have some options now and i'm going to
try to optimize
solitude
loneliness happiness productivity
seeing family
uh
seeing co-workers
the chemistry with the team building
with the co-workers versus just the the
raw
uh exchange of information with the
co-workers it's fascinating to see
how that how that kind of evolves yeah
and then there's the big the third space
idea of you know the spaces where you're
um in a co-working space or a cafe or
something like that or you've got other
people around you but you're not exactly
interacting with them but they're very
much there
and that's huge too
we i don't think we think about that
enough
yeah that energy is there
yeah yeah i i lived in manhattan for 17
years um before we had kids
and i absolutely loved it like i loved
it the feeling of all that energy all
around you but you could be anonymous
within it to me was perfect
you